aquí tenemos la fórmula para un
compuesto iónico y el objetivo de este
vídeo es como podemos nombrar a este
compuesto
bueno claramente podemos ver que
consiste en cobalto y azufre pero como
lo nombramos bueno lo que se acostumbra
es que el primer elemento que aparece es
nuestro catión y si observamos el
cobalto aquí podemos ver que es un
elemento del bloque de y los elementos
del bloque d son un poco engañosos
porque no sabemos cómo se ioniza
exactamente pero sabemos que este es
nuestro catión es nuestro ión positivo
pero no sabemos cuál es la carga en cada
uno de esos cobaltos así que analicemos
el año vamos a analizar el azufre o
mejor dicho el a nyon sulfuro vamos a
subrayar lo ahora en la tabla periódica
aquí tenemos el azufre y como se muestra
en este grupo quiere ganar dos
electrones para completar su capa
electrónica externa como el oxígeno
sólo le faltan dos electrones entonces
el avión sulfuro se ve así 'tenemos el
azufre con una carga 2 negativa justo
como el oxígeno y como todos los
elementos en este grupo necesitan ganar
12 electrones para que su capa externa
se parezca a la de los gases nobles en
este caso para que se parezca a la del
argón así que podemos usar esta pista
para saber cuál es la carga del cobalto
porque tenemos 3 sulfuros y cada uno
tiene una carga
2 - entonces si tenemos 3 eso nos da una
carga 6 negativa y para el cobalto en el
caso del cobalto tenemos 2 entonces
estos 2 cobaltos tienen que compensar a
esta carga 6 - tienen que tener una
carga 6 positiva eso significa que cada
uno de ellos necesita tener una carga 3
positiva entonces si cada cobalto tiene
una carga 3 positiva y tenemos 2 en
total tenemos una carga 6 positiva en
este lado y 6 - en los sulfuros y la
razón por la que esto es útil es porque
ahora podemos nombrar al compuesto a
este compuesto iónico le vamos a llamar
sulfuro sulfuro de cobalto 3
y lo escribimos con números romanos
sulfuro de cobalto 3 ahora tal vez estén
pensando oye cuando observamos los otros
compuestos iónicos no tenemos que
escribir la carga del camión aquí y
bueno la razón por la que en este caso
se acostumbre a escribir el 3 es porque
el cobalto puede tener diferentes cargas
se conoce como polivalente
polivalente porque miren si algo se
encuentra en el grupo 1 sabemos que
tiene una carga 1 positiva los elementos
del grupo 2 generalmente tienen una
carga 2 positiva y si es un halogenuro o
también llamado al 1 generalmente tienen
una carga 1 negativa pero estos metales
del bloque d pueden ser guionizados de
diferentes formas por eso necesitamos
saber cuál es la carga del cobalto para
nombrar al compuesto en este caso
tenemos al sulfuro de cobalto 3 pero
podríamos tener otras ionización es de
cobalto en otros compuestos iónicos pero
en este caso tenemos al sulfuro de
cobalto 3 y podríamos ir en dirección
inversa es decir a partir del nombre
sabemos que el cobalto tiene una carga 3
positiva y con eso podemos construir la
fórmula o como hicimos en este vídeo
podemos nombrar el compuesto a partir de
su fórmula